so
[Music]
this incarnation of the divine being or
the fact that it essentially and
directly has the shape of
self-consciousness is the simple content
of the absolute religion in this
religion the divine being is known as
spirit or this religion is the
consciousness of the divine being that
it is spirit for spirit is the knowledge
of oneself in the externalization of
oneself the being that is the movement
of retaining itself identity in its
otherness
this however is substance insofar as
substance is in its accidents at the
same time reflected into itself
not indifferent to them as to something
unessential or present in them as in an
alien element but in them as it is
within itself that is in so far as it is
subject or self
consequently in this religion the divine
being is revealed
it's being revealed obviously consists
in this that what it is is known but it
is known precisely in its being known as
spirit as a being that is essentially a
self-conscious being for there is
something hidden from consciousness in
its object if the object is for
consciousness and other or something
alien and if it does not know it as its
own self
this concealment ceases when the
absolute being qua spirit is the object
of consciousness for then the object has
the form of self in its relation to
consciousness that is consciousness
knows itself immediately in the object
or is manifest to itself in the object
consciousness is manifest to itself only
in its own certainty of itself its
object now is the self but the self is
nothing alien on the contrary it is the
indissoluble unity with itself the
universal that is immediately such it is
the pure notion pure thought or being
for self which is immediately being and
consequently being for another and
as this being for another it is
immediately returned into itself and in
communion with itself it is therefore
that which is truly and alone revealed
the good
the righteous the holy
creator of heaven and earth and so on
are predicates of a subject universal
moments which have their support on this
point and only are when consciousness
withdraws into thought
as long as it is they that are known
their ground in essence the subject
itself is not yet revealed and similarly
the determinations of the universal are
not this universal itself
the subject itself and consequently this
pure universal too is however revealed
as self for this is just this inner
being which is reflected into itself and
which is immediately present and is the
self-certainty of the self for which it
is present
this to be in accordance with its notion
that which is revealed this is then that
the true shape of spirit and this is its
shape the notion is like likewise alone
its essence and its substance
spirit is known as self-consciousness
and to this self-consciousness it is
immediately revealed for spirit
is this self-consciousness itself
the divine nature is the same as the
human and it is this unity that is
beheld
paragraph 759 is a long one there's a
lot going on in it and i would like to
highlight from the beginning what
happens at the beginning and what
happens at the
end where hegel
is you could say tipping his hand
letting us see
when that metaphor what cards he
actually does have in the hand they
haven't yet been completely
played but if we have these things in
mind we can see
where this section
of the revealed religion
and
of the religion section in general is
actually going
this is a very important
set of points
so he begins with this interesting
word that gets translated here as
incarnation by miller
and you know it's it's fitting i mean
typically we think of incarnation as god
taking on
human shape and
it literally means taking on flesh right
taking on the
body the kind of thing that we
ourselves are although there's a lot
more to it as well i mean we are also
self-consciousness and we're going to
talk about that in just a moment as well
but there's an earlier
not necessarily earlier
sense but certainly a connected sense
god becoming
human god becoming man is often how it's
it's framed you could think to you know
the curdius homo
of saint anselm which is not the first
attempt to provide some sort of you know
look inside the mechanics of
the not just universe and creation and
its fall and redemption but
why it is and how it is that the divine
not only can but should become
human
completely human right and we're going
to see a reiteration of this a little
bit later towards the
end when hegel is telling us
that
the divine nature
is the same das alba right
as the
human
mensliche right
and it is this unity that is beheld that
is intuited
that is being grasped in sensuous
forms as well as cognitively
and effectively
now
in traditional christianity it's not
that the divine and the human nature
are the same
although you could say well they are the
same in the incarnated god the god human
right
in this case
christ
but we want to avoid a confusion here of
saying well human nature is the same
thing as divine nature
but this kind of signals where where
hegel is going
because here's where
in some respects he's
he's different than traditional
christians right
um
[Music]
we're looking ahead
towards seeing
the human community
as being the divine
but that's further down the line so
let's put that off for the moment i
mentioned you know this is just how he's
tipping his hand to some degree let's go
back to that first discussion this
incarnation of what the divine being
actually it's not divine being at that
point
uh miller is transposing the word divine
in there it's just evasing right
but
later on that's going to be um that's
in so you know it's okay it's not not a
big deal
what being are we talking about here the
divine being right so the incarnation of
the divine being now what does this
actually mean
says or the fact that it essentially
and directly
has the shape of self-consciousness
this is the simple content the einfach
inhalt right of what hegel here is now
calling the absolute
religion now absolute is at a higher
level the revealed religion in relation
to nature religion and the religion of
art
what we could call the religions of the
world in other ways and the religions of
the greco-roman
complex uh you know throughout history
going into theater drama that sort of
thing
that is being
revealed as
important but not the absolute religion
the absolute religion is going to be one
of orphan borrowing revelation
revelation in what sense revelation to
whom revelation even more importantly
processed and worked through
in what ways well this is what
it lies in the many paragraphs ahead
so he says that
the incarnation is the simple content of
the absolute religion how do we make
sense out of this incarnation then
well it has the shape of
self-consciousness
the form of a self-conscious being
which exists for other
self-consciousnesses like ourselves
so then he says
in this religion
in this kind of religion the divine
being
is known as
spirit
geist right
um for spirit is the knowledge of
oneself in the externalization
of one's self so this is something
important about spirit not something you
know radically new something that
hegel's been talking about knowing the
self by externalizing the self
this is how we actually do come to
make sense of what it is that that we
are and so to other beings as well and
we can compare and contrast to each
other we're all externalizing to some
degree and we have to by the way as
self-consciousness is because as we know
from the self-consciousness section
self-consciousness is self-consciousness
in relation to another
self-consciousness so there always has
to be some some other ring some
externalization going on
now he says the being that is the
movement of retaining its self-identity
what what it knows itself to be
in its otherness and this is you know
typical hegelian stuff things are
related to their others
self-consciousness is like that spirit
is like that
what do we have going on
so he says
this
however
is
substance
so
um
as in the previous paragraphs we're
going to see a lot of s-words
right a lot of things coming up that are
connected to each other that
reveal or transform into each other
and so we're going to have substance
we're going to have not
self-consciousness per se but
self-conscious being
we are going to have the subject and
then we are going to have the self so
four s's there right
we five if we want to count spirits
right
and uh
you know these are these these four are
s's in the german but spirit geist of
course is not but five in in the english
right
so
what's going on here in terms of
substance
so he says
this spirit right
is substance
insofar as substance is
in its accidents
so we'll come back to that in a moment
at the same time reflected into
itself not indifferent to them as
something unessential or present in them
as an alien element
but in them it is within itself okay so
what are we talking about as substance
there so a substance is something that
remains
uh not necessarily the same because its
accidents could be changing but remains
the same substance
through time so i am a substance you're
a substance you know this chalkboard is
a substance um the lights that i'm using
to illuminate
this is i talked to you are a substance
we can break substances down further
into
you know in the human body organs which
are they substances or not well it
depends you know like aristotle says a
hand cut off is not really a hand
in anything other than an equivocal
sense but suffice it to say we have we
have substances and substances do have
accidents that is things about them that
do change so
aristotle had a whole you know list of
accidental
categories that is things that are
contingent things that happen to be
the case and some of these could even be
things that seem to go very deep like
being a good person or a bad person
hegel by the way is on you know he's
unwilling to follow
along with a substance ontology where
substances are
what they are in themselves and don't
really change i mean
we do in fact change through some of our
accidents even aristotle recognized some
abstinence some accidents are proper
accidents and others like wearing a pink
tie are you know pretty contingent right
so
let's come back to this so substance
is in its accidents
reflected into itself
why is he bringing that up
well spirit as substance
knows itself
through
its accidents
you might say
sometimes this happens through just you
know scrutiny of self sometimes this
happens through
you know seeing it through the eyes of
the other self-consciousness or hearing
their reports about it sometimes it
happens through doing something let me
try on this pink tie not a color i would
typically wear but oh it looks looks
good actually and then i can think about
other things connected with it pink is
associated with uh femininity or you
know things like that and yet
historically that's a new thing that's a
20th century thing because in the middle
ages this was one of pink was one of the
most dynamic and masculine of colors and
you notice all these things that are
packed
into just that one little thing that one
accident right there having to do with
this substance which i am using as
something accidental for myself when i
put it around my neck i am the substance
in this case we could go on and on and
on with examples of how it is that a
substance
can
be reflected into itself through its
accidents
not indifferent to them
not indifferent to them meaning that it
you know the substance is itself
in some way affected by its accidents in
itself right
not indifferent to them as something
unessential
or present in them
as in an alien element
um
what does that last part mean
the substance is not
in
its qualities its attributes its
predicates or determinations as we're
going to see a little bit later as
something merely contingent yeah it just
so happens that this hair
of this color uh on my my face and my my
head
is um attached to this person right no i
i live in that i live in my accidents
and so do other beings and so he goes on
and says
in them in these
accidents it is the substance is within
itself
and here we can now get to the next
thing that is
in so far as it is subject
or self which we're going to come to
very soon
but he goes on and consequently in this
religion the divine being is revealed
open bar right it is it is shown it it
actually it doesn't it isn't just
revealed
it reveals itself
right
this is even more
important as well it's revealing itself
as another
human self-consciousness as well as
divine right
so he says it's being revealed
there's obviously consists in this
that what it is is known okay that that
is pretty obvious revelation
has to do with knowledge right
and then he says but it is known
precisely in its being known as spirit
what is that now now we get to the next
one that is essentially
a self-conscious being vasently
not just zelps uh
you know bivous
self-conscious right but zelps bavous
sein
a self-conscious
being so we've gone now from substance
to self-conscious being it is both at
the same time it's also still spirit
and he says um
there is something hidden from
consciousness
in its object gagenstand if the object
is for consciousness and other or
something alien
and if it does not know it as its own
self
this concealment ceases
when the absolute being
spirit is the object of consciousness
right so
the absolute being here is the divine
being
that is being incarnated being made
human
and
we the believer
the other
self-conscious being is grasping that as
a
another self-conscious being
in relation to ourselves to whom we
could
open up space within our own
consciousness
to allow it in as when we know it as
when we develop intimacy with it as when
we
have desire
for which is hegel not talking about
here but desire for what for recognition
from that divine being and to recognize
that divine being
so he goes on
and he says
this this concealment ceases when the
absolute being crossed spirit is the
object of consciousness for then
the object
the absolute being has the form of
self in relation to consciousness
consciousness knows itself immediately
in the object or is manifest to itself
in the object
now he tells us a few
really important interesting things here
consciousness is manifest to itself only
in its own certainty of itself its
object now is the self
but the self is nothing alien or foreign
on the contrary it is this indissoluble
unity with itself the universal that is
immediately
such it is the
pure raina notion
pure thought
or and here we get some interesting
transitions
it's being for
self in the previous paragraphs we saw a
lot of references to the anzik sign
right or on zeke
now we have the fusique and here it's
explicitly fusique zein right being for
itself
being related to itself and this
he he says
this is very very interesting this is
immediately being mitilbaras
sein right so there is an overcoming of
mediation
happening here
that is occurring through the
self-certainty
the being certain being conscious of
oneself
and what's in oneself right
so he goes on and he he says here it uh
it is pure notion pure thought or being
for self which is immediately being and
consequently
being for another
and as this being for another
is immediately returned into itself and
in communion
with itself
it is therefore that which is truly and
alone
revealed
well why being for self
becomes being
for an other
well because others are there other
self-consciousnesses but now notice that
it's not like you know oh there's that
other self-consciousness over there it
wants to enslave me it won't recognize
me the way i want
no
in the revealed religion with this
incarnate
god
human nature and divine nature being the
same
there is a different relation of
self-consciousness to it
the believer
is in a certain way we could hegel
doesn't say this here but we could say
inhabited by the other
self-consciousness the divine and human
self-consciousness that is how there is
this communion with itself
and that's why he says it is therefore
that which is truly an alone revealed
the revelation of the incarnate god
here's where we go to yet another level
subject
the good the righteous the holy creator
of heaven and earth and so on
he says now what are these these are the
things that we say about
god these are things that we even put
into creeds credos
are i believe
assemblages right we say i believe or
the church believes or we the community
believe we spirit believe
this this this this this you know i
believe in one god the you know creator
of heaven and earth uh all that is seen
and unseen those are those are saying
things about what you believe
about that god and you know one of
them's in here right creator of heaven
and earth right from the
uh creeds uh the holy the good the
righteous
the transcendent
whatever it is
being goodness
right
these he says are predicates
a little bit later you can use the word
determinations
uh right of a
subject
universal moments he says which have
their support on this point and only are
when consciousness withdraws into
thought as long as as it is they that
are known
the ground in essence the subject itself
is not revealed and here we have we're
going back in a certain way
to
what was just said
earlier about having this hiddenness
or having something that is not known
right
so this is another way of talking about
that so long as our understanding of god
is coming through all these predicates
or determinations which are
known both in the sense of like an
individual believer says that that they
know it and they're known to a community
and tradition that uh antidates the
believer and probably will continue on
in the you know worldly way after the
believer is dead
well people do get really wrapped up in
this and they lose sight of the fact
that
the divine is a subject
not just a subject of conversation
not just something for us to be you know
making ourselves subjects of or to
subject in our own way like when we
think that we're better than god and we
get to boss god around god must be this
way this way this way right we're
arguing about predicates
god is a subject in that god has agency
and god has
personality
god is
mensch like right this is a mensch
verdung a a becoming human becoming
humanity becoming like us poor slobs
right
there is that a great song years and
years and years ago what if god was one
of us just a slob like one of us right
what does it mean to actually become
humanity you know
well that is the the subject that is to
be
revealed to reveal itself to to open
itself up you know open borrowing again
right
so he goes on and he says that as long
as
they it is they that are known their
ground in essence the subject is not yet
revealed similarly the determinations of
the universal are not this universal
itself
the subject itself
and consequently this pure universal two
here we get now the fourth thing
is however revealed as
self
for
this is just this inner being which is
reflected into itself
and which is immediately present
present as
somebody that we as we saw earlier can
can touch can see can hear can feel
right can have relations with
can eat fish with right to take a prime
example
reveal this salford is just this inner
being which is reflected into itself and
which is immediately present and is the
self-certainty of the self for which it
is present there's a lot of self's going
on in there right so you have to think
of that in terms of again the believer
and the religious object gagenstan which
turns out to be a subject and turns out
to be a self as well as self self
consciousness and substance
so he goes on he says this
to be in accordance with its notion that
which is revealed
this is then the true shape of spirit
and this its shape
the notion the grave is likewise alone
its essence and its substance spirit
is known as self-consciousness and to
this self-consciousness
it is immediately
revealed so we've got two
self-consciousnesses there spirit is
known as self-consciousness
both the self-consciousness of the
incarnate god and my own
self-consciousness
and
right
to this self-consciousness me
it is immediately revealed for spirit is
this self-consciousness
itself self-consciousness is being used
here in a
kind of different way
isn't it self-consciousness is not just
true self-consciousnesses which exist in
relation to each other but it is
something also that
connects these
two self-consciousnesses
and provides what's going to be a ground
for the recognition that we're looking
for
here's where he ends the divine nature
is the same as the human
and it is this unity
that is beheld right so we we go from
the incarnation of the divine being to
now
the divine nature is the same as the
human
why well hegel's deployed all of this
metaphysical
language or apparatus to make sense of
this
as he's steering us towards
what theologians have called the christ
event the
entrance of as you know kierkegaard and
philosophical fragments puts it of the
eternal into
time
and we could say indeed
into
humanity
you